all right let's bring in will Purdue
Comcast SportsNet Chicago analysts for
the Bulls pre and post game and of
course had a long NBA career will good
to have you on how are you doing well
man I appreciate you having me on thank
you um is Tim Duncan boring or private
he's definitely not boring I can promise
you that but I'd say he's more private
and I just think that he's not one
that's entertained or he doesn't look
too entertaining outside of his inner
circle you were with him what his first
two years in the league yes sir
did you know right how long did it take
before you went oh boy that guy is
really good well I always tell the story
that when I first got to San Antonio we
started to have training camp in Austin
at the University of Texas so the night
before we would all meet jump on the bus
take the bus for the hour ride down to
Austin and I remember david robinson and
i'd sitting on the bus talking and not
in a bad way but just like hey I'm gonna
make sure young fella young fella here
earns it we understand he's the first
pick of the draft but you know we're
just you know as David said we're not
going to hand him anything we're gonna
make it deserve it
and you know he comes in the first day
he's wearing a shorts backwards he
doesn't say much you kind of want to
walk up to him and wave your hands in
front of his eyes and be like it does
anything registering in there and then
all of a sudden about after four
practices what's back then it's two days
I've ever David and I were at lunch were
like I think we're gonna be okay this
guy's good what was he like off the
court though well you know I sent out a
tweet I mentioned the second word I used
was prankster though he's a very quiet
guy but as I always said he would be the
guy and some people's arm and how
immature that's nothing to do with an
attorney that just has to be with him
kind of live inning the situation he'd
be the dude that would steal your
underwear get all wet throw it in the
freezer he'd be the guy that would take
a bag of Oreos
stick them on your car or in my case you
know back then when cellphones and
everything we're still fairly new he
would unbeknownst to you steal your cell
phone
put some funky girlish ring on it and
then go behind a wall and just keep
going so the wringer would keep making
that noise and of course you had no idea
how to turn it off I I had a
conversation yesterday a discussion
yesterday where you know Duncan's
labeled the greatest power forward of
all time which Tim Duncan's one of the
great players of all time I have a
little bit of a problem with the power
forward designation here will if you
spend half your career as a center and
half as a power forward you can't be the
greatest power forward of all time let's
not forget he also spent half a season
playing the three spot okay one year
everybody got her and I played to five
David played the floor and Timmy played
to three and we ended the triple towers
and we had some success with that but
that was just because you know an injury
to Sean Elliott now what Sean came back
that wasn't a case but I agree with you
I think he's one of the best players of
all time
I think it's very difficult to just
label him as the power forward because I
honestly feel like when he first came in
the league he played power forward that
he got older in the team change he moved
into the center spot and I would say he
might have played more sooner than he
did power forward meaning he played more
with his career with his back to the
basket than actually facing facing the
basket would you rather have Kobe's
career Tim Duncan's career oh yeah I saw
I seen all the stats on that and that's
that's like six to have one-half dozen
the other let me let me just say this
I'll gladly raise my hand and say I'll
take either but I tell you that one
thing was that tens career was a lot
less turbulent yeah there was a lot less
drama and that's exactly how Jimmy
wanted it I'm not saying that Kobe
wanted to drama but a lot of times he
was in it
he career
and he stirred it up - I'm talking to
will Purdue Comcast SportsNet Chicago
former bull and spur if how about if I
put Tim in with the other centers where
does he rank if he's the greatest power
forward
where is he as a center all time well
see that's the thing where I I agree
with you I don't just call the power
forward a lot of people want to label in
the best power floret of all time but
that right there just leads to the old
adage that your mom used to tell you the
first impression of the lasting
impression because when he first came to
San Antonio David played center he
played power forward but even then I
think it's people if you go back and
really look at the film will tell you
because of David's injuries he became
more effective as a power forward then
he fitted at center because Tim
conflation but to answer your question
specifically I would go maybe three one
Olajuwon to Duncan three it's I'm sure
I'm forgetting somebody and there's
going to be some of you when your
listeners is emailing as we speak or
texting go up that guy's not what about
Jack well let me pull me back up there
say Jack three Timmy four but that's the
point now I'm getting old enough where
I'm forgetting about remember I saw this
story I knew Steve Kerr got punched by
Jordan I didn't realize you got punched
by Jordan is it is it like a long list
of teammates who got punched by Jordan
well I only know two personally now I
don't know if somebody did before I got
there but I always used to tell the
story I mean that's nothing I was proud
of but it was just I was doing what I
was asked to do you know one of the
things that people don't understand is
that you know it's one of 82 games when
you play an opponent you have a day of
practice you know the second team and in
that case at that time of my career I
was you know still early in the league
but it was BJ Armstrong myself
Gregg Hodges Stacey King Dennis HOF said
you know we'd go down to the other end
and run the opponent's team's high
frequency plays Johnny Bach was our
defensive guru and we go through their
plays and then we go run it against the
starting five and one of the things and
I forgot who was against it might have
been against Milwaukee they kept saying
hey the one thing that they're going to
do is they're going to continue to run
screen role on Michael to trying to wear
him out so we kept running screen role
and I I I wouldn't say my screens were
always legal but I made sure I laid some
woman on I mean he he got mad and he
finally turned around he was listen you
guys do that again I'm gonna take it
upon myself they do something about it
we looked at Johnny Bach and he goes
running again so we ran it again and I
had a feeling I was like I think I'm
gonna pay the price for this so I think
I might have been moving but I got my
money's worth and knocked him down and
when he got back up I thought he was
just going to get in my face
but he took a swing and could happen and
then once I regained my thoughts I
started to chase him around the gym but
they grabbed me and say it's not worth
it you got to realize that you're
chasing did did Jordan dekyon he didn't
that mean he gaves me and you know and I
have to admit and he realized he made a
mistake a lot you were like what do you
mean he ran from I said well you know
when a guy gets pissed he's like I'm
gonna take it out on you he didn't want
to get in there an altercation do you
feel like you guys matches the cross I
think you realized he made a mistake and
he also apologized later could you have
taken Jordan listen I don't know how
many guys out there like all you have
and I was a badass fighter when I was
young
most of the guys is you know in the NBA
it's more of a wrestling match than
anything else
first takedown and went down like a hawk
could you have taken Jordan well I had
to wait on him but he was a lot quicker
than this you know
I have a feeling that you know I might
have gotten a few shots but I may have
not got the best oh I'll leave you with
this the Commissioner is going to kind
of tweak the hacka strategy here
whatever happened to in an intentional
foul will that if I am intentionally
fouling you why not just call it as an
intentional foul with free throws and
you
keep the ball what why do we allow those
fouls to happen when it is an
intentional foul I don't know it's a
valid point sit you know there's so many
different angles you could take on this
and then you start talking about well
you need to be a better free-throw
shooter but you know as the game evolves
and as the fans that watch the games
evolve I feel like there are some
changes that need to be paid I don't
necessarily agree with this from a
player standpoint but from a rating
standpoint from the ability to make it
more watchable I feel like something had
to be done and I feel like a step in the
right direction
it sounds diplomatic there will well the
thing is you got to understand there's
there's so many opportunities for people
to a spin their money be sports to watch
so I feel like you got it you've got to
stay ahead of the curve but if that
means making some tweaks to the game
then do it I mean I I personally love
baseball as it is but the ratings are
declining attendance is declining so I
feel like if they hit baseball wants to
stay alive they have to make some
changes whether I as an individual agree
with it or not yeah but that's like
saying you know hey we can't get Bryce
Harper out so we're gonna walk him every
time and instead of you being better now
because he's better than you you take
him out of the game just call the genius
for doing that I didn't like it I
understand you're trying to win but
that's not why I'm watching a game if
you want me you care about me as a fan
the commissioners got a you know factor
that in you know could you've gone out
of your way and just said hey we're
gonna throw pitches out of the strike
zone here yeah you could have done it
it's semantics you can pitch around him
but you know that's a problem that's a
problem in baseball I can take you out
of the game I can have you go watch
Bryce Harper Mike Trout and I can take
him out of the game and you can't do
anything about it well I agree with you
that's kind of our society we want we
want instant gratification so if I'm
paying big money to go see
Harper and then you end up walking in
four times well I'm gonna tweet about it
because I'm not happy because I spent
all this money but then again we can
also get into the arguing about you know
recipes players during an 82-game season
oh you're taking a shot at the Spurs in
your former coach I'm not playing aside
this burger it feels like it yep it
feels like you're taking a shot at
Popovich yeah I don't know I would never
take a shot if I was biscuit he owns a
winery I like something who would you be
more scared of angering Jordan or
Popovich well considering that I'm out
of the league so I don't have to worry
about trying to ask Jordan it's 92 a
contract I probably be more afraid of
mob [ __ ] yeah I think what people
forget is that it'll be in the military
guy he's one of those guys that was
trained to like go over overseas and
disappear and be a spy well I think
there's certain things he knows about
you to scare the hell out of you it's
pop the number one seed if there's a
fight among NBA coaches I tell you what
well he's not the youngest but there's
probably I don't think pop would
hesitate to take it take a quick need if
somebody's growing we work we worry
about the gentleman's aspect later now
is that a flagrant one or a flagrant two
because I'm not quite sure well and
since we're talking about Tim I'm sure
he would look at the official like Timmy
doesn't say I don't understand what
you're talking about
yeah hey great to talk to you again well
as always thanks for joining us that's
will Perdue the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience